i love this man i've known him since i
walked into los angeles california in
2003
i'll be as i mentioned at the top of the
hour we met around a poker table um
and uh i just enjoy his company
immensely
you've enjoyed his work in shows like
spin city and of course currently on the
goldbergs curb your enthusiasm
also on mad about you your kids
definitely know his voice from
uh carr's film inside out a bug's life
and more
and he is in hudson falls which is
available on amazon this summer
my friend richard kind on the rich eisen
show how are you richard
i just want to go skateboarding with you
that's what i want to do let's pick it
back up again now that we're
of a certain age i think so and by the
way i appreciate you
including me of a certain age when was
the last time you've been on a
skateboard richard kahn
was the last time listen there are
certain things in the world that you
have to acknowledge
you don't like skiing and skateboarding
are two of them skiing i don't like them
you know i don't like speed i don't like
cold i don't like falling down
yes i don't like hurting myself and that
is why i play golf and tennis
now tennis i haven't played tennis with
you i've played golf with you how are
you as a tennis player
richard i used to be very good i'm not
good anymore
okay if you watch another show that you
should mention which is
really really good yes and since your
audience i sort of know what your
audience is like
yes okay and i think that they would
like the show that was on amazon
called red oaks oh yes speaking of
tennis very good
show and that really was the last time i
played tennis
seriously because my son played a tennis
pro
on that show and i had that i had a
couple of scenes where i played tennis
and so i had to just pick it up again
i'm no good anymore did soderberg make
you play tennis to get that gig
richard on that show no no no
uh uh you know you can always fake it
which i
think's looking better than i i am but i
i was on the high school tennis team
so i was okay okay i i had a cross-court
shot that was great
because i was a fat kid and i didn't
want to run so i had to hit winners
and so i would have a cross-court shot
just in between the baseline and the uh
service line
uh and it would hit the hit though the
out of bounds line you know the
and and they couldn't get it and that
was my shot
and uh and once they realized that was
my go-to
it would be like you know i'd win 6-1
6-2
and then it became oh oh and six
oh and six oh and six well richard you
know and now and now you've chosen
another profession which all you do is
hit winners richard we know that that's
all you do is it winners
of course they do of course they do yeah
uh
so before anyway not on the golf course
anyway uh now hold on a second what's
your handicap right now richard
what is it what's your index all right
my index
now is much higher than i want it to be
it's about a 16.
wow i used to be pretty good i know you
go you go from living
in l.a yes and being single to
moving to new york and having three
children and it might
it just ruins your goal
i i do not i do not encourage parenthood
it just kills your golf game uh but
but as you know i've been playing
because i've been out there working yes
and when i uh i've been out there
because of work
and you know let's say you work one or
two days a week on the particular show
that you're doing
that leaves four or five days of which
you can play golf
which i did and i started getting better
again well i'm very happy with that well
we have to play
richard because you know my handicap
currently is just a hair under 20
because i'm
again uh that the weather aspect i've
got for me but you know i've got three
beautiful children
um i know and let me tell you something
yes richard beware
of getting addicted to that place and
the game okay beware i know it is in
fact
golf should be learned by young people
and not picked up again until you're 38.
you have the ability to turn and your
body allows you
to to turn like a golfer should yes but
the game
is addictive and at a young age you
should be concerned
about school and then about work and
business and becoming wealthy
so that you can play golf more often
when you get into your late 30s and 40s
it's life it's life according to richard
kind everybody um
here on the other side i am a life coach
don't come at me with any sort of uh
psychological or emotional problems
everything else i can take care of so
let's talk about why you're out here in
los angeles before we get to uh hudson
falls
on amazon you're you're out here and i i
i know this
from somebody other than you in case
this is a fight club situation you're
not supposed to talk about fight club
you're shooting the current the current
season of curb out here
in los angeles i've been lucky enough
uh to be on this on one of the episodes
uh last year i was on three this year so
far i'm only on the one
uh but having done it and finished it
it's simply hilarious i don't think it
will disappoint
and i got to work with uh people i loved
and i got to work with people i admire
and didn't really know
pat and oswald and vince vaughn oh and
they
are they are superior people
and superior improvisers well and again
and again because you just get basically
the the broad
strokes of what larry and the rest of
the the crew there want the scene to be
about and then off you go
right is that the way it basically works
here's what i liked in it too
i said let's say somebody gives you an o
henry story
okay so you see you read the story and
each couple of pages is considered a
scene and they say you know the
story you know what has to happen go and
improvise
what it would sound like this is not
ad-lib this is improvised yes
and you do it a couple of times and the
more you do it the more
semblance and uh structure you get to
the scene
and you get to what the essence of the
scene is in this case what larry wants
and uh he puts them all together uh by
editing and he gets a half hour out of
it
unbelievable when did you meet larry
when's the first time
and and i'll tell you something the the
scenario that larry wright is
quite detailed it has no dialogue but
everything that he wants
to have you know about the characters
about the emotional state about
what happens in the scene and why it's
important to tell this scene
is all written there like a short story
it's
quite detailed and quite fascinating but
there's no dialogue
you just make up the dialogue when did
you first meet larry david richard kahn
when did that happen uh oh richard kind
uh
did you just do that in because people
wouldn't recognize my voice no
no no i'm on the radio so it's called a
radio reset i'm a lead pipe wielding
professional is basically what i'm
trying to do
you are you know and i was thinking of
this yes you are the luckiest
you and i yes are the luckiest men in
the world and i'll tell you why okay
richard because you
are a gregarious personable
uh wonderful man who enjoys the company
of other people
and you want to learn about them and
what more do you get to do
than have this i don't know how long
you're on an hour two hours three
every day three three hours yeah you get
to talk to people
this is what you love to do when you're
not doing this
what do you love more than anything else
talking to people yes you get to analyze
sports you your whole life is an
extracurricular activity
you you don't have a job
well you you were born to this uh you
know i on the other hand
was born to do what i would love to do i
love
going on a set and playing pretend and
going to act
we are the luckiest men in the world we
are we are
we are we're very lucky i think we just
fell in this
into this that we were lucky and it's
we're just lucky anyway
let's talk more about me what was your
question about
why did you meet larry david it's i
think what the original question
was okay i'm going to tell you where i
first met larry dave because it's pretty
funny okay
i had never met him before okay okay i
didn't know him
but i i you know he sort of knew me i
guess from tv
i sort of know him this is a very funny
story this is the first time i ever met
him
i'm at uh there are two golf courses in
pasadena
uh right called brookside right by the
rose bowl okay there is a hole like the
12th 13th or 14th hole
which is a par 3 and because it's a
public course
there's usually a backup at the par 3.
so we were backed up about two or three
foursomes
so he's sitting there on the bench i
come up and there he is and i recognized
him from friday
he recognized me because i had been on
tv
so we are convivial how are you
and i of course say so what are you
doing
and he says like this okay
he goes i'm working on a pilot
for nbc with jerry seinfeld
now you have to understand you must go
back and clear your mind yes
seinfeld has never been on tv nobody
knows jerry seinfeld
nobody really knows larry david
everybody in l.a
has a pilot everybody that is what they
do
one out of 90 go so he says
i'm working on a pilot with jerry
seinfeld
and i look at him with as much disdain
and condescension as i possibly could
and i go
oh good for you
wow years later it's larry david and
jerry seinfeld
but on that day it was oh very good good
for you
and it's also as condescending as i can
remember
it was as condescending as anybody could
possibly be
and i i told larry about that because i
remember it i remember because
uh uh a friend of mine i do you know
well her name is talia balsam uh she was
married to george
married to john flattery uh two great
men and she is a great woman
a great actress i know her mom i've
known her for years
anyway she actually was cast in that
pilot
and then uh when it was called the
seinfeld chronicles
and then it was re-jiggered and uh they
added more people and they replaced
talia at the time with uh julian and now
the rest is history and that might be
the last time larry david played a
public golf course maybe after all yes
absolutely you're right
you're absolutely oh richard kahn here
on the rich eisen show
but by the way that was another reset
richard that was another reset by the
that was another reset
i just reset that who i'm talking to
richard
oh thank you rich eisen that's very nice
that's what i was doing we're listening
to the rich eisenhower
yes we are by the way that's another we
could use that as a drop
hey uh you mentioned george's name uh
george clooney and um
george has told many stories about you
richard on uh late night television
and um uh the one story that i love
that i'd love to hear from your
perspective
you can't yeah i refuse to talk about it
the cat litter box story anybody wants
to hear
about it there are plenty of avenues you
could read it
you can hear it i think most recently on
howard stern yes
i think he called it on leno but why
don't you tell it
why won't you tell it richard why won't
you tell it
the same thing but but because
everybody's heard it but never from your
perspective we've only heard it from
george clooney's perspective
okay i will tell you the you know i
really hate this
uh and i and i haven't heard i'm sorry
he is a great great storyteller yes and
every once in a while he'll embellish
something
but it's worth it it is worth the
embellishment
he claims that i gave the cat
laxative i did not
okay so start from the beginning you
you're you're roommates and you have a
cat richard telling the story
i'm not telling the story it's called
it's old hat let's let's make this
particular interview
suspenseful and have everybody say wow
i want to hear this story rather than
oh my god not this story again no but
but there's so many listeners who don't
know it richard and again if you don't
let them read it or look it up on google
it's there they're not going to hear it
from me
i don't tell it as well as george he
delights in it
the victim is always you know
the perpetrator tells it with relish and
delights
i'm the boy
i'm the victim i am the person you laugh
at no no no no no richard
richards okay i'll tell you i'll tell
you another great great story but this
the uh do you know that i mean he listen
he calls great practical jokes
yes i once tried i can't even remember i
think i once tried to pull a practical
joke on him okay i might have been
successful
but the retaliation is not worth it
he he is machiavellian he's
rasputin-esque
he just thinks six steps ahead he's
he's just a smart man he's cloning he
thinks steps ahead i don't think i live
in the present
he thinks steps ahead that's why he's a
good director
and uh and you just can't you can't
cross them
and if you do it's uh he he knows it i
remember
we planned a birthday party a surprise
birthday party for him
when i first got to know him and just as
we were walking up the sidewalk to the
to the door yes he flips a note into my
hand
and he walks in and they surprise and i
look at the note he goes
this is a surprise party
he's awful he's just awful he really is
you can't pull anything by him surprise
to you
anyway enough about george he gets his
own publicity yes let's talk about your
show
uh hudson falls on amazon this summer
this is an interesting
sort of thing
yes uh first of all
in the old days people would say oh i've
got this pilot i want to do this pilot i
have this idea
in the old days people didn't want
pilots
they wanted the 87th episode of the tv
series
that you are pitching yes because that's
the only way to make money
but nowadays you don't need a network
you don't need that 87th episode
you can put it on youtube and uh or or
whatever uh um a medium
you want to use amazon netflix whatever
it is this is going to be on amazon
and who knows people might like it and
if they do
then they'll pick it up and look for
money into it
such is the case with this this was a um
the origin is really interesting this
guy elias and i can never eat the greek
last name pantangis i can't
never remember or pronounce it but he's
a wonderful wonderful creative
uh writer and director who had been
approached
by i can't remember who it is
an organization that wanted to make a
pilot that dealt
in science okay so he wrote about
uh women working like in the congo women
doctors nurses
taking care and it was an interesting uh
series but
way too much about science so they came
back to him and they said
you know we really liked the series it
was very good it was beautifully solid
you know the uh the locations everything
like that we don't want it so much about
science we want
science to be a part of it a component
of it
but let's make a really good interesting
so
a real good story so he wrote a murder
mystery
about uh genetic engineering in foods
and stuff like that where the big
company that was doing genetic
engineering were
just sort of the criminals and somebody
uh knew a little too much
and they were murdered and in comes this
uh
pretty decent private eye uh which is me
that's you
sort of a slump not necessarily colombo
but certainly
you know not even sam spade but a guy
like that
i'm a you're a gumshoe you're a gum shoe
you're a guy that is what i am
not a gum shoe richard i'm sure i look
the way that i am a gumshoe a private
dick yes
why not i know your audience uh so
anyway so i'm a private detective and i
look into so we did a pilot
uh the people who are in it are superior
superior bill paxton oh my god he played
the devil
in uh um uh uh the uh villains heads
yes i moved he's a great actor he was a
julius caesar yeah
he's a great great actor so he's in it
uh a jessica heck a brilliant brilliant
multi
uh tony nominated actress who i've been
lucky enough to work with and know
a brilliant actress um uh uh oh who
oh god
wielding professional richard i've got
cardio and i've got information
i try my best prepared for this
interview no i just came to talk
as a matter of fact people think this is
an interview it's not this is rich kind
going
hey my buddy rich heisman how are you
doing that is right it's just
it's two friends together and again it's
hudson falls i have a beer
it's 2 30 in the afternoon for me and i
have a beer because i'm talking to my
good friend rick i love it
and and it's on amazon this summer it's
called hudson falls
uh it's quite it's quite good it's quite
beautiful and what was really
interesting yes richard
is this we shot in july the first thing
we shot in during the
after colbit sort of i don't want to say
relax but actually became more stringent
with the rules right
we got tested it was the first time and
i've been working a lot since july but
this we did in about four or five days
awesome under very strict covert rules
and i think it came up pretty good and
it was
done for when i a song for nothing
it was done it's very inexpensive and it
really came out
uh interestingly i think the story is
interesting
and let's hope that it it does something
i really you know people may want to
watch it
and maybe both to have it continue and
find out who is the killer and who was
killed and things like that
sure it's on hudson falls it's on amazon
this summer richard i appreciate the
call let's uh let me know when you're
back out here we'll tee it up with your
with my index and yours will be
unbeatable unbeatable unbeatable we'll
still take everybody's money
we get so many sides it'll be great
it'll be great candy all around
my love my love to your family please
same to you richard right back at you
that's the one and only
richard kind everybody you will not tell
the story won't do it
look at larry look at ld and richard
right there playing golf
look at that won't tell the story about
the cat litter box that george clooney
has told on literally
every late night show when they were
roommates together go check it out
do google it and understand that richard
did not give the animal a laxative
says george was embellishing there
[Laughter]
fantastic i could not wait to run tell
that to everybody that knows richard
conyer in los angeles that i know which
is about a thousand people
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here